بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
قال الله تعالى قالت الاعراب امنا
وهذا
ادعاء غريب خاصه
اذا
قرات عن الاعراب
ترتيب المصحف قبل ان تقع عينك على هذه
الايه ان الله تعالى يصف الاعراب فيقول
الاعراب اشد كفرا ونفاقه
واجدر الا يعلموا حدود ما انزل الله على
رسوله
وقوله تعالى وممن حولكم من الاعراب
منافقون ومن اهل المدينه مرضوا على الن
والى غير ذلك من هذه الصفات فقولهم
وقول الله تعالى قالت الاعراب امنا قالت
الاعراب امنا
وهذا جاء بالتانيث تانيث الفعل
للدلاله على ضعف الدعوه
كان من الممكن ومن بل من المتوقع ان يقال
قال الاعراب امنا قال بالتذكير الاعراب
مذكر لكن جاء قالت الاعراب امنا والتاهنا
تاء التانيث وهذا ياتي كثيرا في القران
للدلاله على امور
من هذه الامور ضعف الحجه مثل قول الله
تعالى
كذبت ثمود
متوقع
كذب ثمود كذب ثمود
لكن كذبت هنا للدلاله على ضعف الحجه
فقوله قالت الاعراب امنا قل لم تؤمنوا
ولكن الاسلام
يعني ظاهر انقذنا
قد
لهم ان يقولوا
انهم انقادوا ظاهرا ولكن لا يقول
امنا يعني بلغنا الدرجات العلى من الايمان
حتى اكتمل ايماننا والله عز وجل يقول ولما
يدخل الايمان في قلوبكم ولما يعني الى وقت
الكلام الى وقت
اللام الى وقت
الكلام الذي يقول به المتكلم فانه لم يقع
قوله لما لما
حرف نفي حرف جزم حرف قلب مقصود اذا قلت
انا لم ياتي فلان يعني ما جاء لكن اذا قلت
لما ياتي فلان يعني ما جاء الى وقت الكلام
الذي صدر
ولما يدخل الايمان في قلوبكم دخولا
شاملا صحيحا
ينغرس في القلب
وهذا من
عجائب ما اطلع الله سبحانه وتعالى نبيه
عليه
لانهم زعموا هذا الزعم الاعراب قالت
الاعراب امنا قل لم تؤمنوا ولكن قولوا
اسلمنا
لم يمكثوا بعد هذا الكلام
قرابه سته اشهر سبعه اشهر
فاذا بهم يرتدون عن الاسلام ويمنعون
الزكاه
هذا شيء واضح النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
توفي بعد هذا
بقليل بعض العلماء يقول ان هذه الايه سوره
الحجرات انزلت
ترتيب النزول
ترتيب النزول ان هذه السوره انزلت
بعد الحادي بعد المئه والعاشره هذه السوره
يعني قبل
109 صور وبعدها كم من سوره يعني القران
كله على بعضه كم في صور 114 سوره
هذه الايه هذه السوره رقم 110
رقم 110 يعني ما انزل بعد هذه الصوره الا
اربع صور هذه الصوره قريبه جدا من انقطاع
الوحي قريبه جدا من انتهاء الوحي الى رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم بموته
وهذا كان في عام الوفود وعامل وفود في
السنه التاسعه والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
كان في عام الوفود ثم بعد عند قرابه نهايه
عام الوفود ذهب الى حجه الوداع
ثم عاد الى
ثم عاد الى المدينه وتوفي بعدها
ب 81 يوم يعني لما وقف النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم على عرفه
او وقف يوم النحر
وخطب الصحابه
وقال لهم اليوم اكملت لكم دينكم واتممت
عليكم نعمتي
ورضيت لكم الاسلام دينا مات النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم بعدها بواحد وثمانين يوم
واحد وثمانين يوم بالضبط
فهذا الكلام
بينه وبين ارتداد هذه القبائل
في السنه
يعني الاعراب جاءوا الى النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
وامتنوا عليه ومنوا اسلامهم عليه
وسخروا من الصحابه وفعلوا وفعلوا وفعلوا
حتى انزل الله هذه السوره ردا على هذه
الاشياء وما لبثوا سنه الا وارتدوا
وقاتلوا الصحابه رضي الله عنهم ومنعوا
الزكاه
حتى ارسل اليهم ابو بكر رضي الله عنه جيوش
الاسلام
يضبط امرهم
قال وان تطيعوا الله ورسوله لا يلتكم من
اعمالكم شيئا ان الله غفور رحيم ثم شرع
الله سبحانه وتعالى في تعريف المؤمن يعني
اذا هؤلاء زعموا انهم امنوا ونفى الله عز
وجل عنهم هذا الزعم
فكيف اذا نعرف
ونفرق بين المؤمن الصادق والمؤمن الذي
يزعم
وهو بمنزلتي من رد الله عليه يعني هو
بمنزله
هؤلاء الذين اراد الله عليهم كل واحد يزعم
فهذا يزعم انه امن وهذا يزعم انه امن
صحابه رسول الله
يقولون امنا
والله عز وجل يقول عنهم
يمتدحهم بذلك امنا به كل من عند ربنا امن
الرسول بما انزل اليه من ربي والمؤمنون
الى اخره ما رد الله عز وجل عليهم سمعنا
واطعنا صدق الله هكذا
لكن هؤلاء قالوا نفس الكلمه فرد الله عز
وجل عليهم فما الضابط اذا كيف كيف نفرق
بين الذي يزعم والذي يقول
وينبع عن الحقيقه يقول الله تعالى انما
المؤمنون الذين امنوا بالله ورسوله ثم لم
يرتابوا وجاهدوا باموالهم وانفسهم في سبيل
الله اولئك هم الصادقون
فالزعم هذا
امنا قالت الاعراب امنهم لسه بتعلموا في
الصلاه لما قالوا هذا الكلام
يعني في عام الوفود لسه اول مره يجلس مع
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم ويتحدث معه ما
مرتش ساعه ساعتين
فهم يقولون امنا لا ليس الامر كذلك هم لسه
ما ما ضبطوا الصلاه
وهم اجدروا الا يعلموا حدود ما انزل الله
على رسوله
يعني هم ابعد من غيرهم عن العلم وابعد من
غيرهم عن الاداب
الموافقه للشريعه
فهم ابعد الناس ما اعرض الدعوه
دعواهم عريض
وحالهم بعيد فالله عز وجل يقول
يعني هؤلاء قالوا امنا وهؤلاء قالوا امنا
كيف نعلم
الصادق من
المدعي الزاعم قال انما المؤمنون انما هنا
للحصر
يعني ليس
بمؤمن الا من كان هذا وصفه انما المؤمنون
الذين امنوا بالله ورسوله
امنوا بالله يعني امنوا بوجوده امنوا
بربوبيه الله باسماء الله وصفات الله كما
وصف نفسه في القران وصحيح السنه
وكذلك الذي يشرك مع الله غيره
الذي يشرك مع الله يعبد الله ويعبد غير
الله مع الله هل هذا مؤمن فليقال هذا مؤمن
قال قوم هود اجئتنا لنعبد الله وحده ونذر
ما كان يعبد اباؤنا
فهو دعاهم لاخلاص العباده هم كانوا يعرفون
من الله سبحانه وتعالى من الله وكانوا
يعلم وكانوا يقومون بعباده الله لكن
يعبدون مع الله
الهه اخرى
فقالوا ليهود فهموا من قول هود اعبدوا
الله ما لكم من اله غيره فاهموا لا اله
الا الله
فقالوا اجئتنا لنعبد الله وحده
وناظر ما كان يعبد اباؤنا
هذا هو الايمان فالله عز وجل
بما يعلق في قلب
السامع انه اه كانوا يؤمنوا بوجود الله
لكن هذا لا يستكمل الايمان في دين الله
قال الله عز وجل في نهايه هذه القصه قال
عنهم وما كانوا مؤمنين
ما كانوا مؤمنين هؤلاء وان كانوا يعترفون
بوجود الله بل ويعبدون الله بما انهم
يعبدون الله
ويعبدون معه غيره
فعبادتهم لله
فالعدم
وهذا واضح يعني الان مثلا
لو واحد اجى وصلى بدون وضوء صلى بدون وضوء
هل
صلى
هل صلى
ما صلى
ما صلى هو مشابه للمصلي لكن شرعا حكم
الصلاه هادينا ليست صلاه ما صلى
كذلك
كذلك الذي ياتي بعمل صالح
ولم ياتي بشرط العمل الصالح
الوضوء شرط في الصلاه
والعمل الصالح له شروط عشان يقبل
وهذه الشروط التوحيد لازم تكون موحد
ليس مشركا مع الله غيره
ليس جاعلا لله اندادا
الشرك الاكبر
الشرك الاصغر
شرك الخفي على
تعبيرات العلماء وتعريف العلماء على كل
حال
فالمفتقد
بهذا
الشرط
فان الشريعه تنفي عنه
وجود الفعل
مثل هذا الذي دخل المسجد وصلى ثم اقبل على
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وهو ابن راكان وجاء الحديث في صحيح
البخاري فقال له وعليك السلام ارجع فصلي
فانك لم تصلي وعاد ارجع فصلي فانك لم تصلي
حتى قال والذي بعثك بالحق لا اعرف غيرها
فعلمني
علمه هو الذي كان
اخل به من السكينه في الصلاه والاطمئنان
الطمانينه في الصلاه ركن من اركان الصلاه
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال فانك لم
تصلي طب انا صليت لا حكما ما صليت
حكم صلاتك لا شيء صحيح انت قمت
وتحركت حركات تشبه حركات المصلين لكن عند
الله هذه ليست صلاه حتى يتم فيها الشروط
ونفس الشيء هذا الذي يتصدق هذا الذي يفعل
يفعل يفعل من الصالحات ويشابه المؤمنين
فيه صلاحهم اذا كان يعبد مع الله غير الله
او كان ينوي بهذا العمل غير الله مع الله
فان الله اغنى الشركاء عن الشرك
وهذا يقال لم يفعل لم يفعل
فقوله تعالى انما المؤمنون الذين امنوا
بالله امنوا بالله يعني عبد الله
امنوا بالله امنوا بوجوده
امنوا بالله اخلصوا له العباده
ظاهرا وباطنا
امنوا بالله
وصفوا الله بما وصف به نفسه دون زياده ولا
نقصان ولم يتجراوا على الله سبحانه وتعالى
ولا على اسمائه او صفاته
هذا كله من الايمان بالله
قوله
امنوا بالله ورسوله ما هو الايمان بالرسول
نعمل الايمان بالرسول هو التصديق الجازم
الذي لا يقبل الشك
ويقتضي المتابعه
انه
يعمل بعمل ويتشبه بهذا الرسول هذا هو
الايمان
لكن
الايمان بالرسول
له ضوابط له لوازم
بل يصف هذا الايمان بعض العلماء بالاركان
يعني الذي يقول امنت برسول الله
ما هي
اركان الايمان حتى نعلم هذا الدعوه هذه
الدعوه صحيحه
يقول العلماء الايمان بالرسول هو تصديقه
فيما اخبر
وطاعته فيما امر
واجتناب ما عنه نهى وزجر
والا يعبد الله الا بما شرع رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم هذا كله من الايمان
بالرسول انت بدك تصدقه في الاخبار وبدك
تطيعه في الاوامر والمناهي بدك تنتهي عنها
لانه من يطع الرسول فقد اطاع الله
وبقدر تحقيق هذه الاشياء تكون مؤمنا برسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال والا يعبد الله الا بما شرع رسول الله
الذي يبتدع في الدين يقول انا اعرف هذه ما
كان يفعلها الرسول لكن هي خير
لكن هي خير فيها ذكر لله جمع الناس في
مكان طيب وانظر الناس مبتسمين حاله يعني
هذا خير
خير معرف في القران معرف في السنه
مهما كان الظاهر فان النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم يقول
كل محدثه بدعه وكل بدعه ضلاله وكل ضلاله
في النار
زي ما قال كل مسكر خمر كله خمر حرام نفس
الشيء بالضبط
وبعد علماء الكلام حاول ان يثير الشبهات
في هذه المساله هي مساله سهله جدا اليست
كذلك مساله يسيره
يعني مثلا
يا اخوي هذه سنه الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم بدنا اياك تعمل بالضبط اللي انت
بتلاقي فيها واي شيء
مضاد لهذه السنه
فان هذا ليس من السنه
اقرا واضحه جدا ايسر منها ما فيه
ثم ياتي
الناس بشياطينهم
ويعقدون الامور
ويحجرون الواسع على الناس
فيقعد يثير الشبهات
يعني الان واحد بيقوم بعمل عباده
كان الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
ما يعملها واضح مئه في الميه ما كان
يعملها
وزيد على ذلك انه كان قادر يعملها بس ما
عملها ماشي
اي حجه تاتي بها عشان تبرر هذا الفعل حتى
لو كان كله تسبيح كله تحميد وحتى لو كان
اصحابه يعيطوا ويبكوا
ويتقربوا من الله ويفعل ويفعلوا هذه كلها
شبهات
اخبرني اي تبرير لذلك في اشياء كثيره
واضحه معروفه معهوده عند العلماء بانها
مبتدعه من بعد الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
وهذه الشبهه جاء غير واحد الى العلماء بها
الامام مالك رحمه الله ساله
احد الحجاج قال
اريد يعني من اين يكون الاحرام
اخبره باحرام اهل المدينه فقال
اريد ان احرم من القبر يعني من قبر الرسول
صلى الله عليه وسلم
فقال له لا تفعل
فقال
انما هي
خطوات يعني ما في فرق كبير في المسافه
زياده تقوى انت بتقول لي احرم هناك انا
بدي احرمك احتياطا
وعند القبر عند قبر الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم
هل فيها مشكله اي يعذبني الله سبحانه
وتعالى بذلك
يعني انا بقول لك بدي البس حرام
معظما قبر الرسول وبدك تقول لي ربنا راح
يعذبني بهذا الفعل شوف الشبه
يعني يعذبني الله بالاحرام
لانني البس الاحرام
وبانني احرم
يعذبني الله
لتعظيم ورسوله فقال له لا بل يعذبك الله
على مخالفه السنه
في شبهه
مع حد قال
ان الذي يعظم الرسول يعذب لكن تعظيم
الرسول عباده وهذه العباده
نفعلها كما فعلها رسول الله واذن بها
ولا نعبد الله الا بما شرع رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم شيء واضح
فياتي اقوام
بكثير من الشبهات
واكثر هذه الشبهات لا تروجوا الا على
من لا حظ له من العلم
فياتون ببعض الاشياء التي كانت في وقت
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم في وقت الصحابه
ويقولون
بناء على ما اسلفنا فان البدعه على خمسه
احوال
يعني تجري في البدعه ايش الاحكام الخمسه
من البدع ما هو محرم ومن البدع ما هو
مكروه ومن البدع ما هو مباح ومن البدع ما
هو مستحب ومن البدع ما هو واجب
واجب هذه البدعه واجبه
ياثم من ترك هذه البدعه
انظروا الى هذا التقسيم العجيب
وعنه الالفاظ نفس الالفاظ يعني الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم يقول كل بدعه ضلاله وكل
ضلاله في النار كل مسكر خمر وكل خمر حرام
نفس نفس بناء الجمله هل يصح لاحد ان ياتي
بعد ذلك ويقول
انتجنا من جراء البحث
مهما كانت
خلفيه
ياتين ويقول
توصلنا الى نتيجه
وذلك ان الخمر
يجري فيه الاحكام الخامسه من الخمر ما هو
حرام ومنه مكروه ومنه ما هو مباح ومن
الخمر ما هو مستحب ومن الخمر ما هو واجب
هل يقبل هذا احد
ادري ان كثير من هذه الردود وهذه الشبهات
قد
يزخرفها اصحابها
صاحب
المسلم العادي ينظر الى هذه الاشياء وقد
يذهل وقد ينبهر
ببعض الاشياء التي تذكر وتتلى عليه
وقد يكون على
قنوات الدوله الرسميه وقد يكون له طاقيه
حلوه وملونه وممكن كمان يكون عنده ثوب حلو
جدا
وعنده شهاده
وممكن كمان عنده لوحه وعنده قلم ويقعد
يقسم لك
قول يا الله هذا الرجل مليان علم من راسه
لرجليه ممكن يكون هذا صفته
لكن في نهايه المطاف
بسطنا احنا
الكلام جدا
قل له بدعه ضلاله وكل ضلاله في النار
كل مسكر خمر كل خمر في النار هذه نهايه
البحث اي بحث يؤدي الى نهايه سوى هذا بحث
غير صحيح
والف بعض هؤلاء كتبا في ذلك
وقالوا انظر الى عمر فانه فعل وانظر الى
ابو بكر فانه فعل وانظر الى عثمان فانه
فعل والمسلمون اجمعوا على صحه هذه الافعال
وعلى القيام بها وما شابه ذلك وهذه كلها
كلها شبه ولها ردود ورد عليها العلماء
ولم يتركوا منها شبهه الا وفندوها
لكن
القصه بما فيها ان الابتداع
او العمل بالبدعه فان هذا ينافي شهاده ان
محمدا رسول الله ينافي هذه الشهاده
لان معنى الشهاده محمد رسول الله يعني هو
الذي علمني كيف اعبد الله ولا عباده لله
الا
بتعليمه بسنته هذا كل هذا كل
سبب وجود هذه الشهاده بهذه الطريقه لا اله
الا الله لا معبود بحق الا الله محمد رسول
الله لا متبع ومطاع من الانس
من المخلوقين
وهذه الطاعه تكون طاعه لله مطلقا
الا
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم رسول الله هذا هو
هذا هو الكلام هذا معناه
فالذي يبتدع
فانه
يوهن شهادته
والشطر الثاني من الشهاده وذلك محمد رسول
الله يعني الذي
يشرك مع الله غيره فانه
ينقض
من شهاده لا اله الا الله والذي يبتدع
ينقض من شهاده محمد رسول الله
هذا هو المعنى
مهما كانت الاقوال مزخرفه فليس هذا هذه
الاشياء تنقسم الى اقسام
والعلماء لهم
ردود على هذا الكلام الذي ذكرته
هذه
الاشياء التي تسمى
بدعا عند اصحابها فقد يكون المقصود ان هذه
بدع لغويه لا شرعيه
او هي من
المصالح المرسله او ما شابه ذلك لكن ناتي
ونقول الحال
في عصر الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم تماما
هو الحال في عصرنا والقدرات كانت هي هي
ما فعل هذا الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
ونحن نفعل هذه هي بالضبط بالضبط وانا
اعتقد بذلك اننا نتقرب الى الله
على كل حال
امنوا بالله اخلصوا دينهم لله
ورسوله يعني امنوا برسول الله يعني
اخلصوا ومتابعتهم لمحمد رسول الله ثم لم
يرتابوا يعني لم يترددوا عن ذلك ولم يشكوا
فيه
وثم فرق بين الارتياب
وما دونه من الشكوك
الريبه
الريبه المنفيه هي هو الشك الذي يكون في
امر عظيم
ويعلق في القلب
ويكون له اثر في القلب وبقاء هذا اسمه
ارتياب خلاف الشك والمعاني
سنذكرها غدا ان شاء الله في معنى ثم لم
يرتابوا
الى نهايه السوره ما ضال الا لقاء واحد
غدا ان شاء الله
وجزاكم الله خيرا وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين